In the 1960s,
uh,
the decision was made in the United States to d institutionalized.
Many people who were in mental hospitals.
There were a huge number of people over 500,000 who were in mental hospitals.
And because of the new drugs that were available to treat people because of
other developments,
most of those people were released,
uh,
for those who had families and support.
Uh,
they were able often to make it in the community and to continue to have a
lives,
sometimes a very productive ones,
uh,
for people who are poor,
for people who had no one to make sure they took their medicine,
uh,
no one to look after them.
Uh,
many of them ended on the streets,
ended up on the streets.
Uh,
and many ended up in prisons and jails.
Today,
the largest mental institution in any community is the local jail or the local
prison.
So we're going to look today at some of the issues that arise and all kinds of
criminal cases,
but obviously we'll focus on the ones that come up,
uh,
in death penalty cases.
Uh,
all kinds of people with mental disorders come into the criminal justice system.
Some with major disorders,
uh,
some with less,
some who commit major crimes and some who commit petty crimes.
It can range from the homeless person,
uh,
suffering from schizophrenia who camps out on the street or goes in the bus
station and won't leave because that's where they keep warm.
And those kind of people may be arrested,
uh,
and may cycle in and out of jail all the time.
Uh,
it may be a person who has manic episode,
someone who may at a time,
uh,
spend money they don't have or steal cars or,
or steal anything for that matter.
Uh,
but then once they're restored to their medication,
uh,
they may be,
able to avoid the mood swings of being very manic on one hand being very
depressed on the other,
sometime when those people are arrested,
uh,
they become incredibly depressed,
which may affect how they deal with their criminal cases.
And then of course,
there can be the person that believes that another person is controlling them
through their dental work,
uh,
and is causing them all sorts of,
to hear all sorts of voices to have all sorts of delusions and basically thinks
they're tormenting them and walks into the person's office and fires and kills
that person.
So we have a murder case,
uh,
that is a product or a result of someone suffering from mental delusions,
say a person suffering from schizophrenia in capital cases.
Uh,
of course all the cases are going to involve murders.
They're going to involve homicides,
uh,
and vary from time to time.
Not very often,
but from time to time,
uh,
they're going to be cases where their mental health issues,
which go to the issues I'm about to talk about their competency for trial.
Uh,
it may be their future dangerousness,
uh,
for,
whether or not they're going to be a continuing danger to society.
And so the question really can come down to is this person so ill that society
treats them or so dangerous that society kills them?
And we'll look at how these issues arise in the criminal justice process that a
lot of difficulty,
uh,
in dealing with mental disorders,
regardless of what kind of case it is,
and regardless of what the issue is,
let's look at some of the difficulties that the courts have in dealing with
people with mental disorders,
any kind of mental disorders from a,
in any kind of cases,
whether they be small cases or,
or,
or very serious cases.
Uh,
for one thing,
a person may be brilliant,
uh,
one day maybe you bring in composer or may just be a normal average person one
day,
uh,
and may be totally out of touch with reality fluidly.
Uh,
floridly psychotic,
uh,
the next day.
Uh,
mental illness varies greatly from time to time.
people can live normally for some period of time and then suddenly have a break
with reality,
uh,
when things happen.
So this makes it very hard to sort out later on.
Uh,
whether the person is acting out as a result of a mental illness or has just
chosen to do some bad thing and murder somebody or whatever.
Uh,
the severity of the mental illness may vary.
may be the nature of the impairment,
what kind of mental illness the person has.
Uh,
maybe some people are more responsive to medication and then two others,
uh,
than others are.
Uh,
some people would take medication and it will work for a while,
uh,
but it may produce side effects.
And so the person stops taking it because they don't like the side effects.
And then they slowly descend again into schizophrenia,
bipolar,
whatever it may be that they suffer from and their actions change as a result of
that.
Uh,
and it may be stress factors that a person under a tremendous amount of stress,
uh,
who has,
some pathology,
uh,
with regard to their brain functioning,
does not function well under stress.
And it's sometimes the problems they have,
the mental problems,
they have a sort of make it difficult for them to deal with a situation.
Uh,
initial always.
not always,
but very often in cases of mental illness is,
is the person really mentally ill or is the person malingering that is just
pretending to be mentally ill?
And this can often be a very complicated issue because most mentally ill people
that I've encountered at least,
uh,
are very invested in people not thinking they're mentally ill.
They want people to see them as normal.
So they may say,
well,
I was just pretending,
uh,
or I was just acting crazy,
when I did whatever the person may have done a week before.
Uh,
and so there were two ways to look at that.
One,
uh,
this is a very mentally ill person trying to convince you that he or she is not
mentally ill or this is a person telling you they're not really mentally ill at
all,
but that they were just pretending.
Uh,
when they engaged in some bizarre activity,
uh,
beforehand and it very difficult,
it may be impossible to know which is the answer.
Many cases will go to trial where witnesses for the defense will testify that
this person suffers from a major mental illness.
For example,
schizophrenia,
uh,
and other witnesses will testify for the prosecution.
This person doesn't have schizophrenia.
This person was malingering pretending,
uh,
at the time.
And the jury has to sort that out.
And decide based on all the evidence,
not just the expert testimony,
but all the evidence,
uh,
whether or not the person actually has the mental illness.
Uh,
the other question is whether we're really talking about illnesses here,
something that's,
uh,
subject to diagnosis by doctors,
or whether we're labeling,
uh,
behavior,
that goes on,
uh,
in,
in people's lives.
Uh,
psychiatrist may say that after examining a person I diagnose this person is
suffering from paranoid schizophrenia.
They have delusions that people are after them,
and it's because of a problem in their brain,
which makes them paranoid and delusional.
Uh,
another person may look at a person and say,
well,
this person ran away from home,
was truant from school,
shoplifted as a child.
Uh,
did some other things after a certain age.
and they will say that because of those behaviors,
that person is a,
uh,
antisocial personality.
Uh,
just,
uh,
a personality problem.
Uh,
not that there's any mental illness there.
and depending upon what is determined by the court,
uh,
if you're antisocial,
it may be they're just a bad person.
You don't have a conscience.
And so you engage in illegal behavior,
uh,
and that's not going to be looked upon very sympathetically.
On the other hand,
if the person is suffering from a major mental illness like schizophrenia,
then we may look at that person very differently and realize no one chooses to
be mentally ill.
No one chooses a to have schizophrenia.
Uh,
and so there may be a different result in the way we look at a person like that.
Um,
and finally the different language that's used by the mental health profession.
Uh,
and by the legal profession,
uh,
doctors talk and psychologists talk and social workers,
with one set of terms about people's behavior,
uh,
try to assess their behavior,
the reasons for it,
uh,
what to do about it.
And the legal system we're dealing with,
concepts that I'm going to talk about in just a moment.
Uh,
is a person competent for trial.
that's not a medical diagnosis.
That's a legal determination.
Is a person competent for trial.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
the medical,
people maybe talking past the legal people sometimes,
and we may see some examples of that.
Uh,
as we,
as we look at these cases,
uh,
but it's not always going to be,
a lot of doctors do testify frequently in the courts and are familiar with the
legal standards,
uh,
but at the same time,
as I say,
they may not be speaking exactly the same language.
And so what the courts are going to look at is what does that person actually
say about the person and how their thought process works and whether they have a
thought disorder and if so,
how it affects their behavior.
A person can have a thought disorder,
which doesn't necessarily cause them to commit a murder.
Uh,
on the other hand,
a person may have a thought disorder,
say paranoid schizophrenia is,
we'll talk about with one of our cases today,
uh,
in which the person's actions are the result of the paranoid fears that they
have.
I want to take just a quick look,
uh,
at the issues that come up a pretrial and after trial,
with regard to mental illness,
uh,
involuntary commitment,
to a mental hospital.
I just touch on for a second because many people who come before the courts
charged with capital offenses,
uh,
may have been at some point in their life committed to a mental hospital.
That means a court has found that they are a danger to themselves or others.
And as a result,
their freedom has been taken away.
Their liberty has been taken away,
but they've been confined not in a prison,
but in a hospital.
Uh,
sanity at the time of the act defined different ways by different states.
But basically did the person know the difference between right and wrong?
Uh,
could the person appreciate,
uh,
the criminality,
the wrongfulness of what they did or did they have the ability to conform their
behavior to the law?
Uh,
and in some jurisdictions will ask,
did they act out of an irresistible impulse?
All of these questions and determining is this person responsible for the crime
or is this person is suffering from a mental illness which caused them to commit
the crime?
Uh,
not many successful insanity defenses.
It requires a lot of experts.
Uh,
juries tend to be prejudiced against the insanity defense.
Often think the person is going to be released into the community,
if not immediately,
sometime fairly soon.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
insanity defense,
not a successful,
but some cases are so clear,
uh,
that the government may even stipulate that the person was acting by reason of
insanity.
That is as a result of a thought disorder.
Uh,
when they,
when they acted a lot of states adopted statutes,
uh,
guilty but mentally ill after John Hinckley was found not guilty by reason of
insanity for shooting President Reagan to impress the actress Jodie foster.
Uh,
the feeling of a lot of people was that now a lot of people are going to be
found not guilty by reason of insanity.
Uh,
the John Hinckley's family had a lot of money and they were able to hire the
absolute top notch,
uh,
mental health experts to testify in his case,
in the case of a poor person in any kind of case,
but facing the death police,
uh,
the ability to hire,
experts as many and of the caliber as Hinkley's is very,
very unlikely.
But a lot of legislatures pass laws that said,
if a person has found a person can be found guilty,
but mentally ill,
uh,
what does that mean?
Uh,
basically the hope is that instead of finding the person not guilty by reason of
insanity,
there'll be found guilty,
but mentally ill.
Uh,
but the result is the same.
the person can still be subject to the death penalty.
That's not the case.
If they're not guilty by reason of insanity,
uh,
the person can still be sent to prison.
Uh,
and in theory,
uh,
they may get some mental health treatment if they're in prison,
but,
uh,
that may be in theory,
it may be actual what actually happens.
Uh,
the other one is a,
is the person competent to waive their rights when a person has told,
uh,
you know,
you have a right to remain silent,
you have a right to a lawyer,
all of the Miranda rights,
and the person decides to waive those rights and give a confession to the
police.
Uh,
did that person do so with a knowing,
understanding of their rights?
Or when the person said wave,
did they think of somebody waving goodbye?
Uh,
did they really understand what the rights were?
if a person is operating under a delusional system,
uh,
they may have a completely different understanding of,
of what the rights are.
And the same thing for rights to allow the police to search a house or other
things rights that individuals give up sometimes during an investigation,
uh,
of a criminal case.
Uh,
most important competency for trial,
uh,
this is the issue that's critical in many cases.
Whether the defendant has the ability to comprehend the proceedings,
to know what's going on,
know that there's a judge,
a prosecutor or a jury that the defense lawyers there to help that person and
have the ability to cooperate with council.
And that's the issue that we will take up first here.
Well,
the penalty phase issues,
uh,
that come into play,
an aggravation of mitigation,
the person's mental health may be important.
It may be important if they're a future danger to society.
The question I raised earlier,
uh,
is this a person so dangerous that we are going to execute them?
Or is this a person so impaired that we don't hold them to the same degree of
culpability of other people?
Uh,
and that's the second part,
the mitigating aspect of it.
Uh,
that we don't hold people who are,
uh,
mentally ill too or that that may be a mitigating factor that will result in a
sentence less than death at the penalty phase of a capital trial after trial is
over.
They're still mental issues,
uh,
which are going to come up from time to time.
Uh,
person,
uh,
we've talked in these sessions about the post conviction review process that
after a person's been convicted and it's been upheld,
they go through a process of review or they can challenge their conviction.
Uh,
they file federal Habeas Corpus actions,
which go to a federal district court and the court of appeals and couldn't be,
uh,
it can seek review in the United States.
Supreme Court.
Supreme Court said,
uh,
in 2013 in case called Ryan versus Gonzales,
the person does not need to be competent.
So unlike trial where a person has to understand what's going on in the
proceedings and has to be able to cooperate with counsel.
Uh,
the court in Ryan says,
uh,
that because,
this is a backward looking process in which it's mostly record based person does
not have to be competent.
You can go ahead,
uh,
but they're decisions that may be made along the way,
which we'll get to competency to waive post conviction review.
The person decides I don't want to appeal any further.
I want to give up my appeals and be executed and get it over with.
Generally,
when those issues come up,
there's an issue of mental health involved.
And so very often the question it's going to be,
is that person competent?
Does that person have the capacity to make the decision to give up further
litigation or is that person a acting because of their mental illness?
Uh,
and then competency to be executed a is the person aware of the punishment,
uh,
and understands that they're being put to death,
bill cause of the crime they committed.
Uh,
and we'll elaborate on that a in another session.
Um,
the remedies,
uh,
for these various findings,
a about a person if a person is found to be not guilty by reason of insanity,
uh,
they're committed to a mental hospital for treatment.
A person who's found incompetent for trial,
uh,
is sent to a state mental institution and treated and may become competent for
trial.
Uh,
and one of the cases,
uh,
in the readings involves a person who was found incompetent and then 18 years
later was found competent.
So a person can be restored to competency.
Uh,
but there are some people who are,
the courts find will never regain competence.
Uh,
a person who is incompetent to waive their post-conviction proceedings,
those proceedings are going to go ahead,
but someone is going to step in for that person and next friend and maybe their
parents,
maybe their spouse,
maybe their child,
someone very close to that person may be able to carry on the litigation.
Uh,
and then finally in competence to be executed,
a person who does not understand why it is they're being put to death and that
it's punishment for the crime.
They committed,
uh,
that person to be committed.
Uh,
usually to a mental institution,
uh,
and there'll be treated and if they're restored to competence,
if they can understand why it is that they're being put to death,
uh,
then they can be put to death.
Uh,
one question that comes up there,
can a person be forcibly medicaid to make them competent to be executed?
Some courts have said yes and some courts have said no.
But that's sort of an overview of the different legal issues that come up
involving mental health.
Uh,
some cases may involve a number of these issues may be a question of whether the
person was sane at the time of the crime,
competent for trial,
a future danger to society and competent to be executed.
Uh,
it may be that it only will be one competency for trial,
for example,
or it may be that after deteriorating on death row after being there for a
substantial period of time,
uh,
there may be a question of whether the person is competent to be executed.
Let's say a quick look at just a,
what we're talking about here.
Competency for trial,
a rational as well as a factual understanding of the proceedings and sufficient
present ability to talk with a lawyer to consult with a lawyer with a reasonable
degree of rational understanding.
This was in a case called Dusky versus United States.
It was a very short opinion by the Supreme Court.
There's two or three paragraphs.
It was a case that came up,
uh,
on the question of whether Dusky,
was competent for trial or not.
And the court in a procurian that is just by the court decision,
uh,
said,
the lower court was determined,
uh,
whether Dusky was competent for trial using this standard.
Um,
the court has also held at the trial of an incompetent person,
a violates due process that if there is a bonafide doubt about the competency of
a person on trial,
the judge,
if the judge sees some indication that this person may have some mental health
issues,
uh,
then the judge is to suicide.
Ponti raise the competency issue.
More often than not,
the competency issue is going to be raised either by the crime in any bizarre
aspects,
the crime behavior by the defendant after arrest or be raised by one of the
parties,
the defense lawyer or the prosecutor who notices that there may be a question
about whether the defendant understands the proceedings and can relate to his
lawyers.
Let's take an example of one of these cases.
Richard Allen Morin.
Uh,
it was,
uh,
facing the death penalty,
and he decided he was found competent for trial.
Uh,
he decided he didn't want a lawyer.
He wanted to fire,
uh,
his public defender,
and represent himself.
And the court found that he was competent to for trial,
uh,
allowed him to fire the lawyer.
Uh,
he then entered guilty pleas and pled the three charges of capital murder right
then and were sentenced to death.
This was to avoid a,
any investigation of his case or any presentation of mitigating evidence.
Uh,
there was some concern about whether mental factors may have been a part of this
decision.
He had tried to commit suicide just three months earlier.
Uh,
and the question that the Supreme Court looked at,
uh,
in his case got an as versus Moran a was the question of,
was the standard once he was competent to stand trial,
was he also competent to then take over the case and represent himself?
Uh,
the court said,
uh,
Justice Thomas writing for the court said that he was a person who is competent
for trial,
uh,
can waive a lawyer,
and plead guilty person has a right to represent themselves under the case of
for versus California,
which had been decided many years before.
Uh,
and then once the person represents themselves,
they can waive all their other constitutional rights as long as they're advised
of their rights.
They have a right to a trial,
right to a lawyer,
right to conference,
uh,
confront witnesses to appeal.
And if the person makes the knowing intelligent voluntary decision to waive
those rights,
uh,
he,
in this case,
Richard Donner Moran is free to enter a guilty plea right then and the judge
sentenced him to death.
Uh,
justice Blackmun dissented,
uh,
had some difficulty,
with this,
uh,
he said,
first of all,
when the judge took the guilty plea,
uh,
he asked Moran if he was taking any drugs and he said,
oh,
just what they give me it to jail.
And the judge went right on is it's just as probably when he said,
well,
he sort of stopped there and seeing what were the drugs and what were the side
effects of the drugs,
which the justice Blackmun sets out in his opinion,
and expresses a concern that these drugs may have affected the way.
Uh,
Moran was thinking,
uh,
at the time he did this.
Uh,
but he also said our definition of competency is the ability to consult with
counsel.
So that sort of assumes there'll be counsel to consult with a,
it doesn't mean that person's going to be,
uh,
running the case all by themselves.
Uh,
and then he also points out competency to play basketball,
uh,
is not competency to play the violin.
A that a person may be competent to be tried.
They may understand the proceedings,
they may be able to relate to their lawyer.
Uh,
but whether or not that means they can take over the case,
fire their lawyer and decide what to do,
plead guilty,
go to trial,
whatever else.
Uh,
just the fact that they're confident for Tro,
competent for trial doesn't mean they're competent to do those functions.
Well.
A short time later,
a Amod Edwards a comes before the court,
uh,
he's found competent for trial.
Uh,
but he wanted not to plead guilty,
but to represent himself at his trial for attempted murder.
Uh,
the judge in Indiana wouldn't allow it.
He assigned him a lawyer,
uh,
much to Edwards dismay.
Uh,
the lawyer would not raise the defense that Edwards wanted to raise in the case.
and so Edwards appeals the case all the way to the United States Supreme Court
where it decides this question whether the constitution permits a state to
limit.
And actually it's more than limit.
It's really override a defendant's decision to represent himself,
uh,
on the grounds that the defendant lacks the mental ability to conduct a trial to
be his own lawyer.
A supreme court decides a with Justice Briar writing for the court that yes.
What Indiana did was permissible and it affirms the conviction in Edward's case,
uh,
the court points out that,
conducting a trial is very different from pleading guilty,
although pleading guilty is certainly a momentous decision which gives up every
right a person has it trial.
Nonetheless,
the court drew a distinction there and said Moran was just pleading guilty and
that was all there was to it.
This involves conducting a trial,
examining witnesses,
opening statement,
closing argument.
Uh,
the court also talked about the nature of mental illness,
uh,
and it's concern about the spectacle of some mentally ill person like Edwards
conducting his own trial,
uh,
and says this may be more humiliating than ennobling.
Uh,
the question comes up here of the dignity of a person.
Does the person,
is the dignity of a person offended when they make a fool of themselves trying a
case when they don't have any idea what they're doing and they're mentally ill
or is the dignity that they have a right to make their own decision about how
their case is going to be handled?
Well,
justice briar also said for the majority,
uh,
we want trials to appear fair.
So we want when people see what's going on,
we don't want the spectacle as we've seen in some cases of mentally ill people
representing themselves at trial.
Uh,
we want it to appear fair.
Justice Scalia dissents,
uh,
joined by Justice Thomas,
he says the dignity it stake here is the dignity of being master of your fate.
That if you're competent for trial,
then you can make the decision,
plead guilty,
go to trial.
And if you want to represent yourself,
uh,
you'll have a right to defendant,
has a right to do that and that it's unfair to impose a lawyer on a defendant
who doesn't want one.
A particular,
particularly a lawyer who won't raise the defense that the defendant wants
raised.
Uh,
he says this is,
um,
basically to imprison a man in his privileges and call it a constitution.
Uh,
but this was a pretty lopsided decision,
seven to two with only justices Scalia and Thomas descending.
And the result of this case is that more often when people with mental illness
found competent for trial,
one represent themselves at trial,
judges going to be much easier for judges to say,
uh,
we're gonna make,
make you have a lawyer,
uh,
at your trial.
And these things don't come up that often,
but they do come up from time to time.
Uh,
and,
uh,
judges generally don't particularly like pro se defendants.
That is people who represent themselves.
They don't follow the procedures,
they don't know what's going on,
they testify and opening statement and things like that.
Uh,
so,
uh,
this gives judges,
an ability to do that.
The question one might ask is if Edwards is not competent to conduct a trial
here,
uh,
is he really competent at all?
Uh,
why are we trying Edwards,
uh,
when he could be a committed to a mental institution and perhaps,
treated and become capable of working with a lawyer and,
and presenting the defense that he wanted to present or understanding why he
should not present the defense that he wanted to present.
But that's not what the court did in this particular case.
Just want to spend a minute on forced administration of drugs.
A defendant is not competent,
but if you give the defendant a psychotropic drugs,
uh,
he or she may become competent.
Uh,
this came up in the Riggins case.
Riggins vs Nevada.
He was taking 800 milligrams of a mellow real a day.
A one doctor said that's enough to tranquilize an elephant.
Uh,
and the result of it being that the defendant Reagan's is sitting at council
table,
uh,
looking like a Zombie because he's taken so much drugs.
Uh,
and the jury looks at them and thanks guys.
They got it looks like a cold blooded killer.
He doesn't look like he cares about anything that's going on,
but that's not really Riggins.
That's the medicine that's causing him to look that way.
Justice O'connor writes for the court and she says that forced medication
involves,
uh,
an interference with the liberty interest that people have a protected by the
due process clause of the 14th amendment a and a defendant.
She looks at the case of Washington versus Harper,
which had to do with forced medication of people in prisons,
uh,
and even a person in prison has some liberty interest in their bodily integrity,
that unless the person is a danger to himself or others,
uh,
and there is a determination of medical appropriateness,
then a person should not be forcibly medicated.
Uh,
this is summarized a w justice Kennedy a concurring,
uh,
makes another couple of points with regard to this,
first that there's serious due process concerns,
uh,
when the state can manipulate how the defendant looks or how the defendant
behaves,
that trial by the drugs the state gives them and of course the defendants in the
custody of the state.
And it's a state that decides what medication he or she's going to have.
A and because of the side effects,
uh,
which are quite substantial for many of these drugs,
involuntary administration of drugs,
uh,
is acceptable only by showing that the side effects won't have an impact on the
defendant.
His reaction to things in court or his ability to work with,
with council.
This is summarized,
uh,
in the case of cell versus United States came down in 2003,
a where the court said we can medicate of court,
can medicate only,
uh,
if it is medically appropriate,
the person is substantially unlikely to have side effects that will affect the
fairness of the trial.
Uh,
and the court takes into account all the less intrusive measures that might be,
uh,
considered before forcible medication.
Uh,
court also appoints had just as a practical point,
if this person's going to be held in a mental institution for a long time,
uh,
the community is going to be protected and it may not be that urgent,
to forcibly medicate them for trial.
Um,
let's talk about sanity and mitigation.
Finally,
uh,
both of these we find in the case of James Eugene Biggby,
in Texas,
uh,
like all of these cases,
a sad and tragic case.
Uh,
Mr Biggby,
uh,
suffers from schizophrenia or schizoaffective disorder depending on which doctor
has diagnosis.
You take a severe depression.
Uh,
he was hospitalized three times in mental institutions.
He was given electroshock treatments three times.
He was given medication.
Uh,
but it didn't work.
he has a delusion,
which nobody disagrees with.
Mr Biggby believes a,
that people at Frito lay are trying to kill him.
Uh,
he thinks they're sending this green gas through the air conditioners.
they also think they're electronically monitoring his movements.
Uh,
and he's convinced that his friend,
uh,
Mike,
treacle is involved somehow in all of this struggle is his friend is fixing
dinner,
uh,
for Mr Biggby.
Uh,
Mr Biggby kills him and also his 16 month old son wraps the sun and cellophane.
So Mr Big B goes to trial and presents an insanity defense.
Three doctors testified that he can't distinguish right from wrong.
It gives you a sense of how difficult these decisions are because here you see,
some doctors said,
well,
he knew his conduct was illegal or he knew that it was,
or he didn't know that it was morally wrong.
Uh,
so there are all kinds of slicing,
uh,
what it means that he did not know the difference between right and wrong.
Uh,
two other doctors say that he can distinguish right from wrong,
uh,
and his father testifies that he can distinguish right from wrong.
Uh,
so the jury rejects the insanity defense.
the Texas Court of criminal appeals takes a look at it and decides that it's not
going to interfere with the verdict of the jury,
which is almost always going to be the case,
uh,
and affirms both the conviction and the death sentence.
But then Mr [inaudible] case goes to federal court and in federal court,
he raises the question that the jury could not consider his very obvious and
well established mental illness in mitigation because of the three questions
that Texas asked juries to decide,
uh,
in death penalty case was it,
was a provocation as the person in the future dangers.
And was it deliberate?
Uh,
and the judge basically told the jury if you think that mental illness,
uh,
was such that he shouldn't get the death penalty.
Just answer one of those questions.
No.
Uh,
the Supreme Court had already decided in the case of a Penry,
John Paul Penry,
uh,
that you can't do that,
that,
that asked the jury to do things.
Two things that are contradictory.
Uh,
you've got to answer the questions.
Honestly.
Yes.
If the answer's yes,
uh,
you can't just tell them to answer it.
No.
Uh,
because of one factor.
So the court vacates the death sentence in the case opposed the conviction,
but since it back,
uh,
to give Mr Begbie a new sentencing trial where his mental illness will be
considered as a mitigating factor.
Well,
you look at these cases and it shows you the tremendous challenges.
Uh,
two lawyers,
judges,
jurors,
the whole legal system in dealing with people who have a mental illness or a
thought disorder.
Uh,
there's not a lot of agreement,
uh,
in many cases among mental health professionals,
about the diagnosis,
about the severity,
about the extent to which the mental illness affected behavior.
Uh,
and so sorting this out for judges and juries can be immensely difficult.
Um,
and we don't always know,
of course,
that the decision's made were the right ones.
A one wonders also,
as you look at these cases and hear about people like Mr Biggby,
uh,
should courts really be making these decisions,
at least in the very close cases,
uh,
where there's little or no understanding of the person's mental disability,
mental disorder,
uh,
and whether some of these problems and some of these individuals,
might not better be dealt with outside of the legal system.
Uh,
for example,
uh,
through,
dealing with them in mental hospitals or whatever,
like,
uh,
Mr. Edwards from Indiana who wants to try his own case.
Uh,
other difficult issues are also presented by mental illness.
the people that have been convicted and after their trials,
a questions of whether they want to give up their appeals,
uh,
whether they understand why they're going to be executed.
Uh,
and we will take up those,
uh,
issues.
And another session.